welcome to the presentation on ordering
numbers let's get started with some
problems and I think as we go through
the examples hopefully you'll understand
how to do these problems so let's see
the first set of numbers that we have to
order is 35.7% 108 0.1% 0.5 13 over 93
and 1 and 7/68 so let's do this wrong so
the important thing to remember whenever
you're doing this type of ordering
ordering of numbers is to realize that
these are all just different ways to
represent these are all a percent or a
decimal or a fraction or mixed numbers
are all just different ways of
representing numbers and it's very hard
to compare when you just look at it like
this so what I like to do is I like to
convert them all to decimals but you
know there could be someone who likes to
convert them all to percentages or
convert them all to fractions and then
compare but I always find decimals to be
the easiest way to compare so let's
start with this 35.7% let's turn this
into a decimal well the easiest thing to
remember is if you have a percent you
just get rid of the percent sign and put
it over 100 so thirty five point seven
percent is the same thing as thirty five
point seven over 100 like five percent
that's the same thing as 5 over 100 or
50 percent is just the same thing as 50
over 100 so thirty five point seven over
100 well that just equals 0.357 if this
got a little confusing another way to
think about percentage points is if if I
write thirty five point seven percent
all you have to do is get rid of the
percent sign and move the decimal to the
left two spaces and it becomes point
three five seven
let me give you a couple of more
examples down here let's say I had five
percent
that is the same thing as five over 100
or if you do the decimal technique 5%
you could just move the decimal you get
rid of the percent and you move the
decimal over one and two when you put a
zero here it's a point oh five and
that's the same thing as 0.05 and you
also know that 0.05 and 500 the same
thing so let's get back to the problem I
hope I didn't that distraction didn't
distract it too much let me scratch out
all this so 35.7% is equal to 0.35 seven
similarly one hundred and eight point
one percent let's do the technique where
we just get rid of the percent and move
the decimal space over one two spaces to
the left so then that equals 1.08 one so
we already know that this is smaller
than this well the next one is easy it's
already in decimal form 0.5 is just
going to be equal to 0.5 now 13 over 93
to convert a fraction into the debt into
a decimal we just take the denominator
and divide it into the numerator so
let's do that
93 goes into 13 goes into 13 well we
know it goes into 13 zero times right so
let's add a decimal point here so how
many times is 93 go into 130 well it
goes into it one time one times 93 is 93
comes the 10 that becomes a 2 later
we're going to borrow since we get 37
bring down a zero so 93 goes into three
hundred and seventy I think it's C Ford
times 93 would be 360 it'd be three
instead of two so actually goes into
only three times three times three times
three is nine
3 times 9 is 27 27 so this equals C this
equals if we say that this 0 comes a 10
this becomes 16 this comes to 81 let me
say how many times since 93 goes into
810 it goes roughly 8 times and we could
actually keep going but for the sake of
comparing these numbers we've already
gotten to a pretty good level of
accuracy so let's just let's just stop
this problem here because the decimal
numbers could keep going on but for the
sake of comparison I think we've already
got a good sense of what this decimal
looks like it's one point 1 3 8 and then
it'll just keep going so let's write
that down
and then finally we have this mixed
number here and let me erase some of my
work because I don't want to confuse you
actually let me keep it the way it is
right now so there's two ways the
easiest way to convert a mixed number
into a decimal is to just say okay this
is 1 and then some fraction that's less
that's that's less than 1 or we could
convert it to a fraction an improper
fraction like actually there are no
improper fractions here but let's
actually let's do it that way let's
convert to an improper fraction and then
convert that into a decimal so 1 and
actually I think I'm going to need more
space so let me clean up this a little
bit dum de dum de dum dum dum de dum de
dum de dum de dum dum there there I can
have a little more space to work with
now so 1 and 7/68 so to go from a mixed
number to an improper fraction what you
do is you take the 68 times 1 and add it
to the numerator here and why does this
make sense because this is the same
thing as 1 plus 7 over 68 right one in
768 is the same thing as 1 plus 7 over
68 and that's the same thing as you know
from the fractions module a 68 what
68 over 68 plus 7 over 68 and that's the
same thing as 68 plus 7 is 75 over 68 so
one in 768 is equal to 75 or 68 and now
we convert this to a decimal using the
technique we did 413 over 93 so we say
let me get some space so we say 68 goes
into 75 suspicion I'm going to run out
of space with 68 goes into 75 one time
one times 68 68 75-68 seven bring down
the 0 I actually don't have to write the
decimal there 68 goes into ignoring the
decimal 68 goes into 70 one time one
times 68 is 68 70 minus 68 is to bring
down another zero 68 goes into 20 zero
times and the problems going to keep
going on so but we can I think we've
already once again gotten to enough
accuracy that we can compare so one in
seven 68 we've now figured out is equal
to one point one zero and if we kept
dividing we'll keep getting more
decimals of accuracy but I think we're
now ready to compare so all of these
numbers I just rewrote them as decimals
so 35.7% is 0.35 seven one hundred and
eight point one percent and ignore this
for now because we just use that to do
the work it's one hundred and eight
point one percent is equal to 1.0 eight
10.5 is 0.5 13 over 93 is 0.138 and 1
and 7/68
is one point one zero and it will keep
going on so what's the smallest so the
smallest is point actually no the
smallest is right here so this is I'm
going to rank them from smallest to
largest so the smallest is 0.138 then
the next largest is going to be 0.357
right then the next largest is going to
be 0.5 then you're going to have one
point oh eight
and then you're going to have 1 and 7/68
so hopefully well actually I'm going to
do more examples of this but for this
video I think I think this is the only
one I have time for but hopefully this
gives you a sense of doing these
problems I always find it easier to go
into the decimal mode to compare and
actually the hints on the module do the
same for you but I think you're ready at
least now to try the problems if you're
not if you want to see other examples
you might just want to either re watch
this video and or I might record some
more videos with more examples right now
anyway have fun